vous auriez plein de quoi pour défendre
Staline j'aurais dit aux gens qui le
poursuivent
si il n'avait pas mené la guerre contre
Hitler ou seriez-vous aujourd'hui
notre vergèse bonsoir bonsoir bon vous
publiez chez Michel Lafont un livre qui
s'appelle Omar m'a tué histoire d'un
crime tu veux dire quoi maman tu es chez
vous qui avez été tué par Omar ces
personnes la phrase est ridicule
erytragique elle ne concerne pas Omar et
c'est pour ça que je l'ai prise
l'histoire d'un crime c'est l'histoire
de ce qu'on a fait Omar mais pourquoi
Omar ne serait-il pas coupable
Omar ne serait pas coupable pour une
raison simple
le corps a été découvert le 24 juin à 8h
du soir le médecin est venu il a
constater les signes sur le cadavre
parmi les parmi ces signes il y a les
yeux clairs
les yeux clairs indiquent que la mort ne
remonte pas à plus de 6 heures ou 8
heures si nous sommes à 8 heures du soir
la mort remonte au 24 juin lundi 24 juin
le 28 juin il y a eu l'autopsie faite
par trois médecins ils ont constaté les
mêmes choses
au mois de novembre les trois médecins
ont déposé un rapport en faisant la mort
remonte au 24 juin entre 11h30 et 14
heures
et puis au mois de décembre mais tout ça
ça ne collait pas parce que homard le 24
juin à un alibi en béton il est dans sa
famille à Toulon alors le 15 décembre
les trois médecins disent c'est une
erreur de dactylographie qu'aucun des
trois n'a vu et la mort en fait est
antérieure 24 heures seulement ce n'est
pas une erreur de dactylographie parce
que si on a fixé cette date au 24 juin
c'est à partir de constatation qui elle
ne sont pas erronées donc
Omar n'a pas pu tuer Madame Marchal le
24 juin parce que le 24 juin il n'était
pas là
et il a malgré tout était condamné à 18
ans et à magriture criminelle malgré les
circonstances atténuantes et là encore
on constate quelque chose de bizarre
Madame Marchal est une dame de 65 ans
elle a toujours été très gentille avec
Omar
elle est tuée de 5 coups de chevrons
c'est à dire un petit madrier sur le
crâne c'est 5 coups ont été portés avec
une telle violence qu'une phalange a été
coupée quand elle se protégeait que son
dentier plutôt son Bridge a été projeté
[Musique]
le meurtrier lui apportait ensuite 15
coups d'une arme blanche
sur le corps depuis le coup jusqu'à la
cuisse le foie le ventre une blessure de
15 cm et les entrailles de
crime pareil ne mérite aucune
circonstance atténuante si c'est homard
c'est perpète or on lui a donné les
circonstances atténuantes les
circonstances atteignantes expriment le
doute des jurés mais dans toutes les
sociétés civilisées quand il y a un
doute on a quitte on ne condamne pas à
moitié donc pour vous il est pas
innocent jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
est innocent pour moi il est innocent
mais qui a tué alors Madame Marchal
alors qui a tué il faut poser la
question à qui profite le crime Madame
Marchal était une veuve elle était
séparée de son mari monsieur Marchal
depuis une quinzaine d'années elle était
séparée de lui ensuite il est mort il
n'ont pas divorcé
elle est milliardaire elle a un domicile
en Suisse et la luxueuse maison de
Mougins n'est que sa maison de campagne
[Musique]
il y a quelqu'un
à qui le crime va profiter nous ne
savons pas qui on n'a pas cherché dans
ce milieu c'est vrai qu'on a trouvé une
enfant n'a remarqué plutôt une voiture
immatriculée en Suisse
il y a rose près de la maison oui mais
plus que ça le lundi 24 juin un ouvrier
tunisien qui travaille sur un chantier
voisin
et qui de temps en temps peut se repose
et regarde un peu aux alentours voit une
voiture
Volvo immatriculée en Suisse s'arrêter
devant la maison de Madame Marchal en
décembre un homme de 35 ans environ avec
des cheveux blancs il sonne et une voix
à l'intérieur bande qui est et à ce
moment-là lui s'en va or s'il y a une
voix qui répond à l'intérieur c'est
Madame Marchal donc elle est vivante le
lundi matin et cette voiture cet homme
on n'a pas cherché à savoir qui c'était
parce que dès le départ on avait décidé
que c'était le petit jardinier marocain
on a dit vous le savez que s'il a été
condamné c'est parce qu'il a été mal
défendu par vous oui écoutez ça quand on
veut défendre une décision de justice on
met tout sur le dos de l'avocat mais
quand les juges de Los Angeles acquit
les trois flics qui ont lynché un
conducteur noir on ne dit pas s'ils ont
été acquittés c'est la faute de l'avocat
aussi les juges sont racistes parce que
là on s'en fout on dit la vérité mais
pourquoi ne pas avoir utilisé plutôt
votre fameuse stratégie de rupture c'est
à dire de remettre en cause la
légitimité même du tribunal un avocat ne
fait pas de la rupture quand le dossier
est un dossier qui n'est pas de rupture
quand je défends des prisonniers du FLN
c'était un procès de rupture c'est des
procès politiques bon tandis que dans le
cas d'Omar il y avait dans le dossier
suffisamment d'éléments pour plaider
simplement devant des jurés et leur dire
mais voyant il n'y a rien et
essayer de convaincre les jurés et donc
de pas faire d'incident mais discuter
simplement calmement Dieu dossier et
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi cette
stratégie qu'on appelle de connivence
c'est-à-dire discuter du dossier
simplement
Omar Haddad c'est l'affaire Dreyfus pour
vous
c'est pas tout à fait l'affaire de
réfugiés évoquée l'affaire Dreyfus il y
a des rapports il y a des différences
aussi dans l'affaire Dreyfus l'opinion
était contre des Rufus et Dreyfus et ses
amis ont dû se battre 12 ans pour faire
admettre son innocence dans le cas de
maharada ce qui est bien c'est que
l'opinion et de son côté 48 heures après
65 % des Français pensent que le procès
n'a pas été équitable donc voilà une
différence c'est l'attitude de l'opinion
maintenant
dans le la cour d'assise même si j'en
crois le journal VSD à qui des jurés se
sont confiées
cinq jurés sur neuves c'est-à-dire la
majorité était pour son acquittement et
c'est le président qui pendant 7 heures
les a travaillé jusqu'à en faire craquer
d'eux pourquoi
pourquoi le président
a des préventions contre les Arabes
les phrases qu'il a dites au cours du
procès quand la femme d'Omar haddha dit
Omar ne ferait pas de balle à une mouche
par une fine allusion au sacrifice du
mouton pour la fête de l'Aïd el-Kébir il
a répondu oui mais il égorge les moutons
alors que c'est pas vrai d'abord égorger
les moutons est un rite religieux et
deuxièmement Omar Haddad n'a jamais
égorgé de mouton mais là par cette fine
réflexion concernant un accusé musulman
et maghrébin il essayait de soulever le
racisme et la peur de l'autre enfin
quand on a essayé pour salir omahada de
prétendre qu'il avait eu des rapports
avec des prostituées ce qui a été un
échec mais le président a profité pour
dire à sa femme mais c'est interdit par
le courant est-ce que le président
aurait dit
un accusé français breton ou auvergnat
qui trompe sa femme que cette interdit
par l'Évangile notre manière
naturellement il n'aurait pas dit cela
donc il y a là des réflexions qui
tendent à rejeter
Omar radar comme un autre comme un
étranger et capable de tout à vous
défendez aussi jean-Hilaire
dans une autre affaire oui que plus
mondaine oui contre la directrice du
monde des livres oui Josiane Savignon
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait Jean et Daniel il
y a un contentieux entre eux il y a eu
des campagnes de bondes contre Jean et
bernadier à la fin juin dernier s'est
mis à attribuer des noms d'oiseaux à la
responsable du monde des livres il a dit
entre autres qu'elle avait je cite les
phrases qu'il a dites qu'elle avait le
clitoris quereller
elle l'a attaqué pour ça et quelques
sons sentait le lisier
qu'elle avait des cuisses de grenouilles
celluliteuses et grenouille
et il a fait allusion à des vacances
qu'elle avait prises dans l'île d'Oléron
avec une autre dame
et moi j'ai répondu mais écoutez
vous l'accusez d'homosexualité dans un
de vos articles d'ailleurs c'est pas
vrai lui vous accuse de mots sexualité
vous êtes quitte vous dans d'une manière
assez plate et vulgaire vous dites que
son ouvrage et nauséabond et sans
mauvais lui est d'une manière plus
littéraire dit que vous sentez le lisier
je ne vois pas du tout et la différence
sauf dans le talent et le style
enfin clitoris querelle je m'interroge
j'ai interrogé des gynécologues aucun
gynécologue n'a jamais vu un clitoris
que ré-leur
mais quand à faire je ne pense pas que
ça soit une critique ou ni une injure
l'injure aurait été de dire qu'elle
avait un clitoris mou bon ce n'est pas
le cas et qu'à ce moment-là donc c'est
une fausse querelle qu'on lui cherche on
a des photos de clitoris ou pas
bien sûr tout le monde a droit à un
avocat même Klaus Barbie mais là il se
trouve que c'était vous et ça vous a été
beaucoup reproché
vous a coûté cher d'avoir défendu Barbie
ça m'a coûté cher non ça m'a rapporté
beaucoup d'injures
[Musique]
ça m'a valu la considération de beaucoup
de gens
assez inattendus
des gens qui sur le moment certainement
ont dû se dire c'est pas bien ce qu'il
fait et qui ensuite quand ils ont eu à
se défendre
on dit finalement c'est lui qu'on va
prendre parce que quelque soit son
client il se bat pour eux et il est pas
poltron
donc finalement l'effet a été bénéfique
c'est vrai que ça vous a coûté une série
sur TF1 oui je sais vous le savez je le
sais j'avais signé un contrat tout était
prêt et puis le contrat était annulé
pourquoi pas avoir défendu tout vieil
droit un avocat lui aussi écoutez pas ce
que c'est pas l'avocat qui choisit le
client c'est le client qui choisit
l'avocat et puis donc nous viennent on
n'a pas choisi il a choisi maître mollet
de Villers qui est un excellent avocat
et puis en plus je n'ai pas en faire une
spécialité non plus vous auriez surtout
que vous étiez illustré dans le dans
l'état de cause vous auriez plaidé la
même chose que très molette Villers en
France il existe
deux principes fondamentaux qui datent
de la nuit des temps là c'est au bout
d'un certain temps ne poursuit plus de
crise dans un but d'apaisement social
l'autre c'est une c'est dans la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme on ne
peut pas appliquer à des faits passés
une loi qui leur est postérieure vous
rendez compte à quel point ça serait
terrible on poursuivrait dans cinq ans
en vertu d'une loi comprendrait dans 5
ans des gens qui sont avortés
aujourd'hui et qu'ils font légalement
c'est pas possible ça crée une trop
grande instabilité on ne sait plus où
est la loi
ces deux principes ont renonce à ces
principes pour faire ce genre de procès
est-ce que condamner tout vient
valait la peine de renoncer à ces deux
principes essentiels
je crois qu'on peut en discuter je vais
vous citer quelques clients célèbres
vous allez me dire si vous les auriez
défendu puis peut-être qu'elle défense
vous auriez adopté Louis XVI j'ai
défendu Louis XVI un jour à la télé
qu'elle défense avez-vous adopter la
défense que je vais adopter c'est de
dire aux conventionnel j'admire beaucoup
saint-justes et Robespierre mais de leur
dire écoutez c'est pas une manière de
régler les problèmes politiques que de
couper le coup à l'adversaire parce
qu'il arrive un jour où d'autres
adversaires vous coupent le coup ce qui
est arrivé et c'est arrivé Staline
Staline bien sûr parce que plus
l'accusation est grave plus la défense
est intéressante vous auriez québécois
pour défendre Staline j'aurais dit aux
gens qui le poursuivent
si il n'avait pas mené la guerre contre
Hitler ou seriez-vous aujourd'hui
et Hitler justement vous l'auriez
défendu
s'il avait été d'accord avec mon système
de défense qui aurait été quoi
qui aurait été que Hitler est né dans
une société allemande
humiliée par le traité de Versailles le
traité de Versailles a été très injuste
envers les Allemands et les réparations
qu'on a exigées aussi et cela a provoqué
une grande frustration chez les
Allemands et c'est sur la base de cette
frustration qu'il y a eu une réaction
nationaliste qui a amené Hitler
ça va peut-être pas marché ça mais
aucune de ces défenses n'aurait marché
c'est des c'est des affaires jugées
d'avance Dreyfus Dreyfus
et Landru belandre bien sûr
[Musique]
bonsoir Monsieur Ardisson
je suis venu de constater que 70 ans
après ma condamnation à mort on ne
m'oublie pas bah non pas du tout venez
nous rejoindre
maître Jacques Verget un avocat à très
très fameux à notre époque vous pouvez
vous présenter dans le désiré Landry 52
ans à mon actif plus de 300 conquêtes
féminine et à mon passif seulement
quelques petits crèmes enfin vous avez
quand même découpé
10 femmes en morceaux vous avez brûlé
dans votre chaudière
précis monsieur Ardisson je suis malien
avec vous le savez bien dommage que vous
n'ayez pas été là vous auriez
certainement été un très bon très bon
défenseur mais à propos auriez-vous
accepté sûrement
alors comme vous le savez on a retrouvé
dans mon jardin des hôtels ciné des
dents et surtout incarnés sur lequel je
notais les frais de voyage de mes
victimes
seulement des allées simples alors
qu'auriez-vous plaider coupable ou
innocents lui écoutez vous aviez à votre
procès le comportement d'un innocent
je répète l'innocence d'autres personnes
qui sont innocentes ont des
comportements de coupables parent-ils
sont gênés dans leur défense mais vous
vous étiez très habile vous aviez une
défense d'innocent vous étiez
convaincants la présence d'ossements
dans votre jardin de provérien
finalement
et les billets simples signifiait
simplement que les belles restent chez
vous pour faire la grasse matinée
pendant que vous rentriez à Paris
vous êtes rassurés ça ne m'étonne pas
nous on ne met pas les gens dans des
chaudières on les dématérialise ici
mettez-vous bien au fond de votre
fauteuil
fermez les yeux
alors Jacques c'est la première fois que
vous rencontrez l'Android oui en chair
et en os oui grâce à vous est-ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes le meilleur
avocate France non sûrement pas
ce que je voudrais qu'on dise de moi
c'est que j'ai apporté quelque chose de
nouveau et que je ne suis pas comme les
autres ça c'est sûr et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu